Chris.
Jeremiah.
Congratulations, you've
made it to the final round
of this competition, which
means that you're both one
step closer to the title
of Forged in Fire Champion
and a check for $10,000.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is-- a pair
of Viking War Axes.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you five days.
[music playing]
It feels good to be home, back
out where there's no people.
I'm not a big people person.
Today I'm making
two Viking Axes.
I've made some tomahawks in the
past and some axes in the past.
I use a lot of
low-layer Damascus
so I'm going to do
one 17-layer billet.
Hopefully out of that I can
get what I need for both axes.
This is a bigger billet.
Normally I start
with a 13-layer.
Lucky me.
To get them both
turned in the eye-form,
I'm just going to cut
a little 2-inch piece
off an inch and a
half round stock
and then I can start
turning the eye.
Jeremiah's been bladesmithing
for a few decades
and I've been doing it
for a couple of years.
So I'm kind of the
underdog so to speak,
but I love the challenges
that come with that.
I'll feel good when it's
done and it's right.
Probably another three
days before I'll feel good.
I'm excited to get working
on these Viking Axes.
I'm taking the advantage
of having two forges
so that hopefully I can
have it done twice as fast.
If I learned anything from
the first two challenges,
is that I need to stand on
the shoulders of giants.
I'm going to stand on
the shoulders of history
and I'm doing as close
to traditional as I can.
What I'm going to do now is
put this one into the gas
forge, switch to the
other one out and get
them both to the same spot.
My biggest concern is
that I get them identical.
Being a blacksmith, people
want things that look
exactly the same all the time.
So not to say that it's
easy, but it's a challenge
that I'm prepared for.
They're identical.
I'm pretty happy with
what I got done yesterday.
Pretty much have all
the forging done.
I can go on to the heat-treat.
My biggest concern, just a nice
even heat all the way around.
The heat-treat is everything.
A lot of things can
go wrong-- twist-age,
the warp-age, breakage,
bend-age, --age, whatever.
If it's not heat-treated
then it's just
a pretty looking wall hanger.
Yeah, she's straight.
Time to do it again.
Two for two so far.
It feels good to have the
heat-treat successful.
I don't know if you
could tell it or not,
but I was pretty
nervous, you know.
I'm forge-welding
a high carbon
bit into the body of the axe.
Making a durable edge
which is historical.
I'm so nervous, I'm shaking.
Whenever you do a forge-weld
there's always the chance
that something could go wrong.
If the welds fail, I
won't have anything.
[bleep]
They got way too thin
right up back here,
the seams are showing, the
welds are not going to hold.
This is the worst thing
that I could have imagined.
I need to start over.
I'm in big trouble.
There's no room for
these emotions right now.
I have a job that
needs to get done.
I don't quit until
the work is done.
Today is all about
getting the handles fit up.
I'm doing the pressure-fit.
There's no epoxy,
there's no pens.
It's a purely mechanical fit.
It just slides on in the tap
and locks it into place and--
If the pressure fits not
right any good shock to it
could drop it down.
[bleep]
One of my taxes doesn't
match the other one.
The bottom's wider than
the top and it needs
to be tapered the other way.
So the only choice I have is
to do it from the top down
and put a wedge in it.
I guarantee that Jeremiah is
going to do a pressure-fit.
Because that's the way
it's supposed to be,
so I didn't want
to be the guy that
took the easy way out
and just put a wedge in
and call it good.
The most annoying thing is
is that it's historically
not correct and hopefully that's
not what bites me in the ass.
As you know I'm still
nursing an injury.
To be my arm today I'm
bringing a special guest
from Marcaida Kali.
Please welcome Staff
Sergeant Chris Manz,
today he will be my arm--
or arms to test your weapons.
Chris, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Chris, let's talk
about your Viking War Axes.
On the initial cut the long
beard that you have right
there, hooked all the ribs.
And of course, the beauty
of having a secondary weapon
is that when he pulled it
out, he had enough attacks
to disemboweled everything.
Overall sir, your Viking
War Axe will kill.
Thank you.
Jeremiah, shall we do this?
Yes, we shall.
[music playing]
All right, Jeremiah,
your Viking Warrior Axes
are razor sharp.
It not only blew
through the ribs,
but dug in breaking through
the lungs and into the heart.
It is fast and light
and it will kill.
Thank you.
To test the strength
and overall construction
of your War Axes,
I'll be throwing
them three times with
each axe into our mock-up
of a drawbridge.
Now hopefully they'll stay
tight and right, not loosen up.
Chris, you ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Chris, first off--
they're balanced nicely
and they match, which is
really what I was looking for.
That stout edge though
kind of keeps them
from penetrating overly deep.
You can see right
about here there's
just a small role in two spots.
But they're solid,
they're still together.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Jeremiah, you're ready?
Didn't get
dressed-up for nothing.
[music playing]
So first off, Jeremiah, they
feel like they weigh the same.
They definitely throw the
same and having that curve
on the blade, allows
them to dig a lot
deeper than having a flat edge.
But the bottom-line is neither
of your blades took any damage.
Well done.
Thank you.
To test the sharpness of your
blades, see how they held up,
I'm going to take your
axes and deliver it three
shots to these three fish.
Chris, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Well, Chris, the gods
of war will be happy.
There's blood on your axe.
It's a good day.
The shape of that blade,
I was a little concerned
just because it's flat,
but it really just
cut right through those fish.
Very, very sharp
blades, well done.
Thank you, sir.
Jeremiah, you're up.
You ready?
Time for sushi.
[music playing]
Well, Jeremiah, same effect.
Your axes are bloodied.
They're now honorable
Viking War Axes.
They are beautiful.
I like what you did
with the copper inlay.
I'm not a huge fan in
how thin the handles are.
To swing it took a little
bit more finger gripping.
Two very well-made axes.
Obviously sharp.
Well done.
Thank you.
Chris.
Jeremiah.
The judges have
examined your work
and they've tested your weapons.
They've made their
final decision.
The Forged in Fire
Champion is Jeremiah.
Congratulations.
Chris, your axes did
not make the cut.
Doug Marcaida will tell you why.
Chris, both weapons performed
equally all the way through,
but in the strength
test, one of your axes
took damage on its
edge that made us
decide that you're going home.
I understand.
Chris, please
surrender your War Axes.
Always disappointed if you
don't win, but the experience
that you get from
this competition,
I've loved every minute of it.
I'm going to go back home
and keep making knives.
And I'll probably make a
Viking Axe on the side.
Jeremiah, congratulations.
You are our new Forged
in Fire Champion
and that's a title that comes
with a check for 10 grand.
How do you feel?
That's amazing.
You did excellent work.
Please present your
axes to the judges.
I did it.
I won Forged in Fire.
To be validated as a smith
this way, is really cool.
This is a win for my family.
Certainly a win for
the history books.
Stay in school, study
your history and it'll
come in handy.
[music playing]